Is there Minecraft music?
No Minecraft music?
Option?
Music?
No Minecraft music?
So, wait.
Minecraft music?
None?
Maybe not.
Oh, there it is.
Yippee!
My, my, boo!
Hello everybody.
Hello.
Oh, we had Raiders.
Welcome in.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Minecraft.
It's like you cannot be on Minecraft screen without the
Minecraft music.
Even though we're not even playing real Minecraft.
No, this is real Minecraft.
We're playing Minecraft.
Take off.
Thank you.
Rest in glitch phase.
I can't see if to thank you.
Thank you guys for the gifted...
Classic Minecraft music.
Too good!
Also, I might need it on for our spooky scary maps today.
Yippee!
Teller and welcome back!
Thank you, thank you!
Curse of Quiet!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
The whole year of membership!
Maddie!
Thank you!
Minto love concert!
is next week.
I'm scared.
Don't remind me.
Oh God, the concert's, oh God, the concert's, I'm gonna
throw up.
The concert's next week.
Oh, wow, Legends Anu, Densetsu, thought Yexi's first ever.
Three, the, live.
Crazy, crazy, crazy You got this Congrats on the new song
Yes!
Also, also I was asked to be a Guest A guest Singer for a
song with Hebe For a web tune A quite popular web tune Tomb
Raider King And And the song is called Unbound.
It's on Hebe's channel.
But I am a shared collaborator, so I think it shows up on my
channel as well.
I'm not quite sure how that works.
It's getting an anime this season.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was kind of crazy when they asked.
I was like, oh, oh, hiyao!
Oh, hiyao gozaiyama-yesu.
um so crazy crazy i got that i got that email and i was like
is this even real is this even real
um yeah tomb raider king and heavy heavy's voice was so
awesome so please listen listen to it even if you don't read
the the webtoon that's okay that's okay um whoa it does show
up if you scroll down to collaborations oh thank you i feel
like i should move that up a little bit on my channel i'll
try doing that later um but yeah your voice is awesome thank
you i was really nervous because heaviest vocals are like so
impressive i was like
whoa you listen to it already thank you thank you thank you
thank you are your body pillows going to restock probably
not but that won't mean that i will not um make new ones in
the future it's way too early but would you ever consider
putting on a christmas tree ornament as merch i wish more
vtubers had christmas tree ornaments A little plush minto
and a winter coat would be cute.
That does sound pretty cute.
A plush might be difficult.
You could always have a minky plush and turn it into an
ornament.
Actually, I was just thinking the other day that I left all
my ornaments at my old cafe.
Because I had some cute, like, anime ones and things from
games and things.
And I left them all...
I left them all...
in like storage whoopsie both my kamiyoshi doing a song
together was just incredible it was also really funny seeing
both your and heaviest fans get confused who was singing the
english is me the korean is heavy i do not know any korean
no i know and and and that's all the Korean I know that's
literally it she's basically fluent I don't even know how to
say where is the toilet I don't even know Chagel, thank you
so much for the one you six months, thank you thank you
thank you Yeah, crazy that I was able to do something with
that kind of high caliber.
Hopefully next time.
Hopefully next.
Right, we do OST for WebTune.
And maybe next, maybe next, anime song.
No, wait.
I have to, no, wait.
WebTune, WebTune.
I have to follow the order maybe.
WebTune, OST.
Then game.
Game song.
And then, and then, anime.
Hopefully, fingers crossed.
Up next, Edo Gay.
That could count as game.
That could count as game, right?
Hamito, you're extra cute.
Stop it, stop it.
That counts as game.
Yeah, it counts as game.
Edo Gay.
The gay is the game.
Edo game.
game with Lost Word.
I guess so.
But that was a cover.
That was a cover of an official song.
So not quite.
The gay is the game.
But it's a cover.
I want an original.
Hopefully one day an original song.
Hopefully.
I think Yeah Original song for game And then somehow anime
Somehow anime Don't Minky will be big in Japan soon Trust
Trust You can wear Oh my gosh Wait what if I made those
shirts that say I'm big in Japan But instead it says Minky
is big in Japan Minky is big in Japan Believe, believe,
believe There we go Howdy Minky, howdy I wear it all over
Japan I might have some stuff coming up
I might have some stuff coming up but Uh Hot dog indeed
Whatever it is will also be available worldwide as well.
Yes.
Greetings from France!
Bonjour!
The Wii Baguette!
So glad to be able to catch you up on stream for my
birthday!
Wii Baguette!
Happy...
Birthday!
How'd you say birthday?
Joyous anniversary.
To you!
Oh!
Really?
Wait!
No!
Can you send all those streamlabs and all those super chat?
I'm so sorry.
Joyous.
Joyous annivers?
Sale.
What does that mean?
It means happy birthday!
It means happy birthday in French!
Also JB, thank you.
Also today I've lost 25 pounds this year.
I have under 300 pounds.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
Let's go, JP!
All this good news today.
Yeah!
Speaking French like that.
I can speak any language.
I'm gonna speak.
I'm gonna speak, I'm gonna speak.
I'm gonna speak Finnish.
right now
I said happy birthday and finish please do Dutch
no there's
Yeah, to you!
How do you say happy birthday in French?
Happy birthday in French!
Please say happy birthday in Australia next.
Oi mate, happy birthday!
You see what?
Or something?
My kamiyoshi is a polyglottis.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Those YouTube videos of the people that go around and being
like, I'm going to little China in my town, and I'm going to
speak Chinese to them.
And they're going to be so shocked because this little white
ghost is speaking Chinese.
That's me.
Except any language.
Any, anything, anything.
Yep.
Wait, if I type this in.
Miffy.
Miffy!
Wait, I thought Miffy.
Wait, Miffy.
Miffy's name is not Miffy.
What is it?
Oh, gosh.
Um, oh, I can't remember.
It's, oh, ninjit.
Yeah, like, ninjit.
Right?
Ninjit.
Can you do sign language?
Actually, I can do American sign language.
Well, just a little bit.
I can do the alphabet mostly.
And I can do my...
elementary school song.
I can do my elementary school.
I can't sing it because it might dox me.
But I'm doing it right now.
Why?
Because they taught us.
They taught us the American Sign Language of our school
song.
In elementary school.
Can we hear it?
No, I'm Sorry.
I can't.
I can't sing it.
It literally has the name of the song or the name of the
school in the song.
You had an elementary school anthem?
I did.
And they would teach us ASL, like, quite often.
The fact that you remember is...
Is... Is... Is wild?
Oh, I just...
Well, we did it, like, almost every single day.
for many years so can we hear the song in ASL
Ningche it's pronounced Ning and Ningche am I saying it
right
that's my address and social security number in the song
that's literally part of it there there's that rapping part
of the song that goes all right everybody I'll spell it out
what's your address What's your number?
Social security?
Say it loud and say it proud.
I live right here.
And you can call me here.
Three digits on the back.
Here is my mom's card.
Take a picture, upload it to the net.
Everybody can use it now.
that reminds me of that one that what's it called that guy
there was like that service that was just like they won't
steal your identity we will prevent them from stealing your
identity and to prove it I'm gonna drive around New York
City with my with my social security number on the on the
truck and and then and then his identity got stolen
And then it got stolen.
Yeah, he got caught.
Part of me feels bad.
Because it's like he had that much faith in the product.
You know?
And they did him so dirty.
They are still in business somehow.
No way!
Wait, really?
What song is this?
What's Minecraft vinyl is this on?
He did take a big bite of the burger, to be fair.
They could buy them the barb.
Boomer's still using it in the big 2026.
That's crazy, though, because, like...
That's crazy.
I'm surprised that...
That didn't...
Completely ruin them.
You got the...
Oh wait, Uba, Uba, Uba!
Yeah, we sang at Smash Australia convention.
We sang the...
We sang the Chikawa song, Pajama Parties No Uta.
And honestly, that song was stuck in my head every time I
would finish practicing it, and then after the concert too.
I can't, I can't, I don't, I don't have it memorized though.
I had to read the lyrics because the lyrics are like, it's
gibberish almost.
Minto,
are you going to do the Hamtaro dance at Legends of New?
I can't spoil anything for Legends of New.
new but i will say that it is a seated theater so it is not
a free standing it is there are seats so if hamdaro were to
be done we did consider this when choosing the set list as
well um so uh maybe maybe that explains our Or that maybe is
a hint of an answer.
Maybe that will be a hint of an answer.
We considered that people will be sitting and not able to
run around for a song that is so run around and excitable.
And that maybe would not be as fun.
So maybe we thought about that when choosing the setlist.
Current song I have stuck in my head is Hot Limit by TM
Revolution.
Yeah!
He was on the first take recently.
My man was up on the mic.
It was beautiful.
My friend showed me Dokoro-chan years ago when I was a
Normie.
I will go through the seats if I need it.
If needed.
JK, I get it.
Yeah.
Oh, Dokoro.
When you were a Normie, that is like...
You had to have been a little bit.
A little bit.
Your friend had to have known is what I'm trying to...
Your friend probably showed you that because they thought...
They thought...
That you would vibe.
Yeah, the signs were there.
Yeah, yeah.
Closeted otaku.
They knew you were a weirdo.
Convert them.
Woo-lo-lo.
Next venue, Nida Hamtaro.
omash pit.
I agree.
What if instead of running around, we'd pass around pen
lights and UOs in a circle?
If you could coordinate that, I would be very impressed.
Whiss!
Thank you so much for the 10!
Keter!
Thank you!
I'll stand as much as I can, but I have an old man back.
Please forgive.
That's okay.
Honestly, I don't know what concert etiquette is anymore in
the state.
because I see sometimes people going to concerts and if
they're seating, people sit.
But, and then they'll get, and then I see like sometimes
occasional TikToks of people being like, these people were
standing while everyone else around them was sitting and
it's rude.
But I go to Japan and when concert happening, stand.
When MC is happening, sit.
so i don't know if people will stand or sit i i don't know i
don't know if a friend shows you dokoro china means your
friend saw the otaku signs of wanting to be bludgeoned by a
cute angel so true speaking of which hope you have a great
story i'm going to thank you for his name that's why mc
parts are for resting yeah i think i that's what i i think
it's it's weird sitting when it's high energy songs i agree
i'm short so most of the time it sucks oh jordan jordan
jordan i understand i have i whenever i go to idol live
unless it's like a very small idol group i give up on being
able to see 100 my intro the dokoro chan was from amv hell
no not amv hell
I'm just there to vibe mostly.
Yeah, I don't, I don't, most of the time I can't see
anything.
That's okay, though.
I'm, I'm, I'm having a good time.
No, that's kind of sad.
Well, sometimes idol shows in Japan will have a girl area.
Not only for that reason, but also because if, you know, if
some fans could get kind of rowdy, but I, I like, I don't
mind the rowdiness.
I mind the being able to see this.
Oh, my shoulders are here for you, Minto.
Kappa!
That's why lift is so fine.
It's a shame concert venues can't stick tall people in the
back like school photo day.
But that's not really fair for tall people, too, right?
It's not fair, you know?
Tall people should deserve to be up close sometimes, too.
like left to right you know what i mean like left side is
short people but if you get there early you get towards the
front and then middle is medium-sized people and then right
side is tall people but you still gotta get there early to
get close up you know what i mean that sounds the most fair
i'd say that'd be huge put me in office i will campaign on
this i campaign on this thank you for supporting tall
people's rights Vinky well I mean I get it like I can be
upset as much you know I could be or not upset I could be a
little disappointed if I'm like at a concert and there's a
really tall person in front of me but then there have also
been really tall people in front of me that have turned
around and seen me and been like oh please go ahead of in
front of me and I'm like oh that's so nice because like you
know I'm just one person they're just now they're just one
person behind right they're not that much far away i will
build a saddle on my head so me too can be up there your
your your shoulders are really gonna hurt though i think
your neck will collapse your neck will collapse space the
source i always step to the side during concerts because i
feel bad but you can't help it like i said i could be like
kind of sad about it but like Like, in the end, I think
everybody, you know, like I said, tall people are people
too, and they deserve to have fun as well.
And it's not fair to shove them in the back just because
they're tall.
As a tall person can confirm, I'll put myself in the wings
or I'm back on purpose.
I can see from wherever.
I don't want to block folks, so.
How tall are you?
You can see from wherever.
I remember going to the, during Phantom Thief a couple years
ago.
Gosh, that was a couple years ago.
That's crazy.
I went to the Hollow Live concert as well.
I could not see the entire concert.
I was tempted to stand on the chairs.
Just so that I could.
I could see.
But I just vibed to the entire concert.
I was like, oh, I can't see anything.
That's fine.
It's more awkward because it's like...
Where do I look?
Do I look at people's butts?
I don't know.
What do I do?
Do I look at the butts?
Of people?
Because I can't see the screen?
I don't know.
That Hall of Life concert was not super set up well.
Yeah, I remember some people complaining about it.
That might be a good show.
Okay, if you are in front of me and you are very tall at a
concert, you better give me a show, baby.
but I'll be looking at.
My girlfriend is also super short, so we just make sure
we're high up or something.
Yeah, that works.
That works.
But if the theater is not slanted, then it kind of doesn't
work.
There is no high up.
I booze at squat day.
Let's get after it.
Yeah, baby.
It's going to be my first off-Kai.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, there's so much happening.
There are the meet and greets for the maid cafe.
Those went up, so apply for the lottery if you want to try
to meet me or Matara.
There's the general off-Kai meet and greets.
There's the concert.
There's a panel.
There's some other stuff that hasn't been announced yet.
There's the British Exchange concert that Densatsu is also
in.
What else?
The caramama.
I was like, you're sorry.
I'm late, long day at work, and it was a hot one.
So I had the spray pull for my paint sprayer exploded.
But it's okay because I didn't spill paint.
That's my man.
Not spilling paint.
Yeah.
A month or two ago, I went to a Korean rock band concert
that came to my city.
I was near the front stage.
5-11 tall.
Got death glares from all the short people around me.
I'm so sorry I played basketball as a kid.
You know what, Ghost of Mid?
I also played basketball as a kid.
And I am literally one foot short.
shorter than you so unfair what is this sitting in the back
is a tall person not to be considerate but just to make sure
minto isn't looking at my butt that's not gonna stop me 511
short king i put my 410 wife on my shoulders okay stop
bragging to all of us hi minto hope you're doing wonderfully
you too brandon thank you for 27 bones thank you thank you
Cannot be stopped.
No, no, no.
You were too good at B-ball, they had to nerf you.
Were you in the kids league in high school?
No, I was in the kids league in like baby school.
Heard you needed this free super mint.
Here you go.
I needed it!
Who is telling you that?
Who is...
What is... hold on.
Oh.
Okay.
I need it.
I needed that.
Thank you, Perth.
I don't think it was free though.
You're gonna have me turn it into Vicky.
New outfit tomorrow, yippee.
Well, hopefully.
I have some good news and I have some bad news.
Good news is that I finished everything on my end for the
new outfit.
Bad news is, I have still not received everything for...
I still have not received everything for...
for tomorrow.
It may have to be...
pushed until Monday.
I was trying to decide how much...
I was like, oh, maybe I could do the weekend.
but I was like I was like I how much time can I give them
how much time can I give them to give me the stuff you know
extra time I was like maybe Saturday or yeah I was like
maybe Saturday and then I was like oh my gosh that's the
World Cup finals Saturday and Sunday on the World Cup finals
and I don't want to stream over that and then I was like
Friday and then I was like looking at my calendar and that's
Phoebe's anniversary stream so I do not want to stream over
that that would be so rude and and so I'm kind of I was like
okay well Monday was when I was going to be doing my six
month or sorry not six but six year anniversary well so it
will be a new outfit debut six-year anniversary extravaganza
most likely six whole years now one bo combo I wanted to
kind of split them up so that I because I have something for
six year anniversary as well but I'll probably do it the day
after or something hmm
so i'm really sorry that it will most likely be delayed
unless i get both things that i need literally in tonight or
tomorrow morning um but yeah uh we will have a stream
tomorrow oh geez wait what will i do instead uh because i
was thinking saturday if i did saturday i could doing a
Saturday, which is what, blues?
but yeah.
10,000 more years of Minky.
That's a lot.
Yes.
10,000 years.
And you better be there, Osenia.
I better see you in 9,999 years from now.
I better see you super chat one more time saying one more
year of Minky.
I want you to schedule that, put that in your calendar
literally right now.
Do you have the Diver DLC?
That's always an option.
I had some other things that I was looking at.
So, yeah, we could do something.
We'll do something.
Tomorrow will be a stream at the very least.
If not, buy a new outfit.
I'm so sad to delay it.
but it will be done it has to it will be debuted before off
guy because there are people that have things that will be
at off guy of my new outfit 27 month check-in out of a
thousand years let's go yay 10 000 more is a great start brb
accepting on death and lichdom i gotta be there yeah you're
you guys don't want to miss year 8337 that one okay i have
big things planned that year that year is crazy that's crazy
year forever mito and i boo six seasons in a movie no wait
that's actually cursed it'll never happen gosh i miss
communities so much all the time did you guys ever watch
community That was actually my introduction.
I know a lot of people probably know, like, Childest Gambino
for Donald Glover, but community was my introduction to him.
Did it ever get a movie?
No.
Binto until the heat death of the universe.
You don't have to apologize if you have to delay it.
It's all right.
We know you work really hard on it and you want to do the
best you can.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I do.
I do want it to be very... I do want it to be good and
everything.
Is year 800813 gonna be... Oh, year 800813 is gonna be,
right?
It's gonna be booby.
It's going to booby.
Boo!
I finally got the birthday bundle!
Yeah!
Thanks for ordering!
I'm definitely going to be sitting for the 8,000 year show.
You should be.
That's like, that's the year of Minky.
Year 8,000.
Year 8,000 is the year of Minky.
Trust?
I met Dan Harmon at a bar once and gushed over community.
I love that guy.
No way!
That's so fun.
doesn't he also have a dnd something or other i think like a
dnd podcast ish or something something i will be there on
ghost listen to his podcast it was weird harvin quest yeah
yeah yeah yeah not sure if he still does to end sometime
right dnd campaigns can't go on that forever right i mean
that was also a long time ago he also has a little show
called that's right i forgot i forgot he co-created rick and
morty it's my name to nisen yeah
I stay in touch with a high school friend and we hang out
maybe once a year and we do the Troy and Abbot handshake at
the end.
We've been doing this for like 12 years.
Stop.
Wait, that's so moi.
What?
That's so moi.
That's so cute.
Birthday bundle arrived recently.
Thank you for ordering it.
I know that I'm sorry the orders have been quite slow.
Actually, we were talking about this the other day with the
Setsuna staff, and they were saying that their current
struggle right now is the office is not big enough for the
amount of merch that they have.
So, still waiting on yours.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
If you ever need an update, feel free to email them and say,
Mint said it was okay to email you and ask for an update.
So they are looking to expand into a new office, though.
So hopefully that will help some stuff.
But in the future, I have no other merch.
Well.
Yes and no.
any future merch that i have in the upcoming months is all
pretty small pretty small things so yes yes yes my dnd
campaign has been going on for nearly four years and we're
only level nine so forever is not unreasonable wait that's
crazy wait level nine out of what
him you mean average no i mean like the size of the stuff it
should not be any giant fumos oh 20 okay i've only played
dnd one so i think i might be busy 10 000 years from now so
here's a supine advance oh really you can't you can't just
put in your calendar and Mind yourself?
All the small things.
Meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
I will not meow.
Meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
All the meow things.
Meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
Cat version.
Yeah.
Shall we play Minecraft?
I have a couple games that I got.
I got Anomaly Game.
This is Chicken Minky.
This is Hallways Game.
We have The Smiling Illusion Game.
We have Escape from...
Sorry.
The title gets me every time.
We have Escape from Haunted Alcatraz Game.
We have Back to School.
It's chicken minke for last chicken minke is actually it's
because it's a craft mine not minecraft It's the only thing
I didn't delete.
I deleted all my worlds for this escape from haunted
alcatraz But we'll just go in order.
I did not test any of these I was literally working on
stuff.
I am afraid of no block Thank you for the super chat ways.
Thank you.
I I Did not test any of these we're just doing it live baby
because I was literally exporting stuff until one minute
before stream so I'm scared of skew first we mint then we
craft let's mint craft we're doing it live I think hold on
let me make sure let me see I think okay yeah so this one
should work why is it red though in the grim darkness of the
far future there is only mint there will be one lone
computer alive at the end of the universe one lone computer
playing my stream we'll do a countdown to the end of the
universe together because you're on 1.21.1 no way did i
download the wrong thing oh my gosh Hold on, let me install
it.
Installations.
Wait, okay.
New installation.
21.
There we go.
Where is this one?
Unnormal.
Okay.
The other one's...
should work on the next thing though okay it's installing
already joined the game what do you mean is it loading oh
it's really tiny why is it so small whoa is it it's really
nostalgic like seeing these screens right anyone else I'm
sorry I have to customize.
Small craft.
Small like Minto.
Small like your mom.
She was a really nice lady.
Shall we try Anomaly Game?
Let's do some Minecraft horror games, baby.
I just felt like playing Minecraft, but I didn't really
necessarily want to start a new world.
And I never have tried some of these horror games before.
I just found a couple.
that seemed funny to me and interesting.
And I said, yeah, let's go for it.
if these are fun, maybe we'll do more in the future.
Things to keep in mind.
Game, oh, game mode.
ADV at all times.
Difficulty peaceful.
If failure to TP click again.
What?
If you think there's an anomaly, go to the exit.
If there is no anomaly, go to your bedroom and press the
note block.
Can you survive till day 21?
Did someone say party at the end of the universe?
I'm bringing the harmonica!
I, gosh, I was like kicking myself today thinking about how
I missed the orders on the Outer Wilds vinyl.
And all I wanted to do was listen to Outer Wilds music and I
couldn't.
Yeah, it's like exit 8.
This map is meant for one player.
Day one is always no anomaly.
Oh.
Made by this.
App here.
Thanks, App here.
Okay, so.
Shall we go?
Hello?
Uh.
Right click.
Alright, there should be no anomalies here, huh?
Oh, I can't go in.
Okay.
Is the music supposed to be playing, I wonder?
Oh, I can't go in here as well.
Interesting.
Minecraft music.
What kind of anomaly can happen in Minecraft?
It's the pig.
I recently had a song stuck in my head, but couldn't place
it.
Asked my bro, and turns out it was the main theme from MGS2.
I'm a fake fan.
You know what this calls for?
Another MGS run.
I get it though.
Sometimes that happens to me where I'm like.
I.
I have a song stuck in my head.
And it's from the most obvious thing.
And I obviously know it.
But I don't know what it is.
Okay.
Yellow flower.
Is the Minecraft music going to take me out of this?
A microwave.
sink anything in here nothing in the barrels maybe nothing
in the barrels and piggy i was humming it for like two hours
wow skelly dino dino skelly a pinocchio we got two jars here
where's my bedroom then
Wait, how am I supposed- It said go to your bedroom.
Is this not my bedroom?
But I can't go inside.
Oh, maybe that's not my bedroom.
Where's my bedroom?
Oh yeah, red flower.
Orangle flower.
Is this my bedroom?
I'm afraid of getting jump scared with the Minecraft music.
Now we're on day two.
Wait, but it said, okay, it said if it's normal, go to the
exit, or no, wait, wait, what were the instructions?
What were the, what were the, thank you so much for the pop
gift.
Red orang.
All the paintings are the same.
This looks normal, right?
But where do I go then?
I won't let me inside.
She forgore.
I did.
Yellow flower.
I think if it's normal, go to your room.
But what's my room?
What's my room?
There is...
What was that?
Can you guys hear that?
Oh, I guess?
This is my room.
Okay, and then the note block down here.
I understand now.
This is the exit note block.
Okay.
We know it now, we know it now.
So upstairs is normal.
And then downstairs that note over there is...
If bad.
Oh.
Day three!
I
don't want to get job scared!
What if we...
What if there's nothing out of the ordinary ever?
Yellow flower.
Nothing in the bathroom.
Because I can't go inside.
Everything's normal.
Everything's durable.
Okay.
Where's Freddy Fives boar?
He'll definitely come on day four.
Yeah, red orang.
It looks normal.
We got to day four.
What if it's Borkin?
And We just, we just cruised through this, baby.
It's, it's, it's totally normal.
Uh-oh.
What is this, he meant collabing with App here?
My kamiyoshi.
Of course, of course.
Can you make it to date 8008?
What?
Is the game broken?
Piggy.
The scary part is that it's always fine.
I'm too good at this.
Wait, we have to go until day 21?
Okay.
Alright.
The anticipation is killing me.
I know, I feel like it's gonna like...
Like Donald Duck us, you know?
I'm like letting my guard down too much because nothing is
happening.
And then it's gonna be like...
Spookiest face you've ever seen.
Monotony is the true terror.
Day 8!
Oh, oh, I accidentally stepped forward.
Not even realizing.
Like, my finger just went down.
Day 9!
I'm just gonna go upstairs.
Kionkun, Dema!
Guys, are you 10?
terrified are you freaked out
are you so scared right now
we have only 10 days left we have app here is not even
trying i think
is he even trying
watch i bet nice
Watch this.
What?
There was an anomaly!
Wait!
There actually was one!
What was the anomaly?
The bookshelf and the entrance was full.
This thing?
That's a bookshelf?
No stinking way.
This game is actually working.
Okay, you know what?
I prefer that, though.
I prefer that.
I prefer that we fail because...
Otherwise, it feels like the game is broken, right?
Okay, let's check the bookshelf.
We know it's working.
Hmm.
We're going to be in a loop again.
Oh, eee-oh.
If it were 50-50 chances, you just got a 1 in 2048.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
I'm checking the bookshelf.
How did you guys see that?
How did you guys see that the bookshelf?
Is this always full candle?
Oh, man.
Now I'm going to be paranoid.
what the bookshelf near the bathroom what this one what was
wrong with it
oh wait failed dot dot dot dot guys at this rate we're not
going to make it to day 21 we're not going to make it to day
21 this is so bad This is so bad.
Was it the candles?
No, it wasn't.
It was the potions?
I looked at them, though.
They're green and green.
Green and green.
Red and orang.
The point is you have to pay attention.
Oh, geez.
They're asking a real lot of me.
me.
Hachibandeguchi like a wardo.
So, that's a
flower color.
Red and orang.
Wait!
What did I miss?
Was it this one?
Oh, no.
really bad at this you guys oh oh oh oh oh oh how did we
make it to day eight how did we make it before how did we
make it a
red and i even said a red and orang
the bookshelves were different these i'm not used to this
this texture yet
eight eight okay all right i'm paying attention i'm paying
attention i mean i've been paying attention just not very
well apparently
the living room shelves had purple books these ones oh my
gosh
red and orang red and orang wait did they originally have
the purple or in the last thing one that I failed, they had
purple.
If all the anomalies are going to be bookshelf-based, and
the one you failed.
Oh, they changed it to purple.
I see.
Hopefully they're not all bookshelf-based, because I will
fail.
I will not make it.
Yellow flower.
Bookshelves look the same.
Bathroom looks the same.
Red Red and Orang.
Looks the same.
Alright.
Red floor.
The books are the same.
Four candle.
Red yellow flower.
Microwave.
Hmm.
Red and Orang.
Why yeah.
Wait or more jump scares for the table and some dweller slop
for the ghost here?
What is a dweller?
Wait.
Eee.
Okay.
There ever be ceiling anomalies.
I sure hope not.
Well, there are no...
Okay.
Red, yeah.
Orang, yeah.
Potions.
Alright.
Okay.
Hi, Bullslop today on your recommendation.
I had pancake salad and it was yummy.
That sounds good.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Where's these always crafting tables?
Oh.
The rendered distance.
I was like, the flames are out.
Yes?
Okay.
You start to question everything.
this looks this looks right no you are definitely not the
only one wonder what the painting wait which one oh the
painting which one was wrong oh it was higher oh my gosh I
didn't even I thought I was only looking at if it was the
correct painting okay all right i'm locked in i'm locked in
i don't know if this is horror or not nothing has happened
can you survive to day 21
i don't even know what the change was
what was it is render distance an anomaly i'm i'm honestly
wondering that because the candles were weird, right?
Like...
They're on... Maybe it was the candles.
I thought it was just the render distance.
I thought it was Minecraft being funky.
The music is so chill.
Okay.
It must have been.
Look, now they're on every...
I...
They're on every time.
I was... I was a fool.
I was a fool.
They can change that?
That's craziness.
It looks fine to me.
Maybe.
The music doesn't fit the horror map, though, but it's chill
so we ball.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yippee!
I guess because typically these anomaly games horror so like
they have horror elements to them um oh wow this one's fun
okay oh my gosh our first one you guys yippee me oh really
really easy spotable one it's so fun and I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed it.
Yeah!
This all looks correct, I think.
Yes.
I believe in us.
I believe I was getting to...
Was this always here?
Yes, right?
This is always here?
I think?
Okay, maybe they can.
there okay
the candles actually were a render bug no way the candles
were working but they were acting funky that's what's
throwing me off the most like are they supposed to be on or
off you know
Oh, I think they're just being buggy.
I think it's fine.
Yeah, it's just some Minecraft jank, exactly.
I think this is fine.
Yeah.
So the one where the candles...
I don't know if that one was a bug or not.
I think it's fine.
Do you guys think it's fine?
I wonder how like in depth I do I have to be looking at the
blocks in here
different flower no I'm scared to answer because I'll blame
you I'll blame you if you were wrong I'll say how dare you
give me the wrong answer how dare you one guy
me she hates us this looks right too but I'm getting bored
we'll go to day 10 we'll see if we can go to day 10 and
our response will be hmm looks
fine to me What was wrong?
What?
No way.
What was wrong?
How is it not fine?
The curtains.
An item frame.
I have a black shield.
Wait, what do you mean?
How did I fail?
That was
an anomaly.
One of the shrub and the light blocks were swapped upstairs.
Are you for real right now?
Oh, I pressed it twice.
Oh, my bad.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I'll have a shield now.
for anything that might come and get me.
If
I get this right, if this one's an anomaly, or not an
anomaly,
okay, one more, one more.
Hi, Mint.
Hello, Raffle Chief.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
Please, something happen.
Anomaly X, leasing off this job simulator.
Truly, truly.
It's like so hard to quit, though.
Because at the same time, you're like...
Something's gonna happen.
Nothing's going to happen.
Nothing is going to happen.
Alright, alright.
Let's play it, let's play new game.
We'll play hallways.
What if all the cool stuff only happens once you get past
world, once you get past day 10 though?
Such a fun memory game.
Thanks, Mint.
Of course!
Whoa.
The way it loaded.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh, your game has been updated to adventure mode.
Why are there bees buzzing?
Welcome to the back rooms, everybody.
Begin game, remember to check settings?
We're in the bathrooms?
What's in there?
Sanity report lists.
Oh, there's bees in there.
Oh.
I thought these were cosmetic.
That's sad.
Lore.
Enabled.
Light FX.
SFX.
Enabled.
They use a bees and the beacon for like the sound effects of
the of the lights.
That's kind of funny.
Difficulty.
I want easy.
I had to wake up so early today because, oh my gosh, I
finally, I, I, I got to do my, um, my new haunting license
today, but, but I had to drive so far to get to it because
the one closest to me was not accepting any appointments for
the foreseeable future.
and I'm like hello this ghost needs to hunt may I please
have a haunting license and so I had to drive very far it
was like a three-hour trip and so yeah I'm so sleepy now and
I had to I got it like a really early in the morning
appointment because I was like what if they get backed up
day and then you know my appointment is pushed like an hour
or something haunting stream win always always I'm always
haunting you so yeah I'm sleepy yawn I'm sleepy mood mood
has changed to disable no we can keep the mood note you may
have low TPS values when playing this to check these press
F3 2 it'll show Aim for 18 plus.
If you don't, then turn down render distance.
Recommended to have an audible volume.
Let me know if the buzzing is annoying, though.
Okay, let's see.
Cloud, let's see.
Video settings.
Cloud's off.
What else was there?
chat shown
it's not too bad okay smooth light on particles all
brightness moody wait brightness smooth light on particles
all brightness moody brightness moody
and then I said render distance like 8 or something right
brightness is all Oh, at the top.
No.
Wait, this?
Oh!
No.
Question.
Eight or more?
Oh, okay.
Oh, brightness is here.
There we go.
Moody.
Okay.
Render distance.
Sure, sure, sure.
This is fine.
Whoa.
bright oh it gets all creepy so creepy now
ooh you see change the preset so the clouds are on again oh
I did thank you all right I'm doing easy mode sorry I'm
doing easy mode I'm so sorry Oh gosh.
You got sucked in.
Something's happening.
Oh.
Whoa.
Okay.
It loaded.
Due to recent events, async requires hazmat usage.
I'll put on it.
I'll put on a hazmat.
If you want to live, you're gonna need to wear this.
Whoa!
Look at me, you guys!
Look at me!
So cute!
KV31 Chapter 3MGDST.
What's over here though?
Huh.
I'm all swagged out.
Yeah, this is fun.
oh god here we go never oh oh oh
wait am I supposed to be here what is this I go back up Wow
cool just like half-life oh you scared me
Oh, it looks like you got a mission today.
You'll be heading to the null zone.
Basically, make sure that you've got the hazmat suit on.
Alright, first you gotta run a diagnostic.
It's simple, really.
Flip the switch.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's fast talker.
Run diagnostic.
Open, close, threshold lock.
Uh.
Oh, I start with this one.
Okay.
scanning magnetic interference status stable scanning solar
solar flare status low scanning cameras and microphones
status bad bad bad oh camera C 26 C 27 not active reporting
to database oh no electromagnetic generator strength status
stable next you need to manage the threshold lock the lever
there opens and closes it don't mess it up it might cause
more trouble than you want to deal with just flick it and
wait it's not rocket scientist sign that's not i'm not a
rocket scientist for now the for the thresholds
temporalization sound fancy it came straight from dictionary
.com just to press the button it'll adjust oh he speaks too
fast oh is that supposed to happen
threshold temporalization it's not rocket appliances anchor
created 2035 the button for the threshold alarm system is
next press it to your to arm it or disalarm the alarm disarm
the alarms if you hear any beeping someone probably screwed
up somewhere now the next the big one the threshold start
sequence pull that lay lever and kickstart the whole thing
it's kind of important so don't mess it up once it's going
you should see some lights or something that should mean
it's working I did it beginning the procedure.
Wow!
This really is Half-Life.
Crispy K!
Happy birthday!
Lastly, there's the threshold magnetic strength.
The dial over there controls it, just tweak it until it
feels right.
I mean, there's probably a correct setting, but who really
knows?
Just don't go overboard and it should be fine.
This thing?
Four.
Spooky.
Wait, how do I change it?
Oh, here we go.
Is that good?
Cool!
This is neat!
More?
Vault opens.
Crank it up to 12, baby!
Oh!
I think I messed it up.
Your game has been updated to spectator mode.
I'm jiving?
I'm jigging.
End portal opens.
Whoa!
Oh.
Good job.
You at least have the IQ of a monkey.
Here's the mission.
Go to the null zone.
It's a strange neighborhood, but don't worry.
Just go in and come back out.
Use the locator to find your way.
No funny business?
Is that what he said?
Okay, bye.
It was a cutscene.
That's crazy.
I want to say that even though I'm a newer fan, I've been
loving your stream to karaoke as Chris BK.
Thank you so much.
Sorry, the text on that was so fast that I was paying
attention to it, but...
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Oh, yeah, we can read it for here.
Use the look at...
No funny business.
Yeah.
We got food ration.
And we've got our location.
Is this Minecraft music?
Should I turn this off?
I can't tell.
It's my birthday too.
Take a happy birthday!
Yeah, I'll turn it off.
I thought there would be maybe some music so what am I
supposed to be oh god oh geez sometimes it loads stuff and
it's they gave
you a walkman when you signed up oh truly yeah la la la
walking through the back rooms I'm in the back rooms I need
to go to the back bathrooms in the back rooms if we just
always go to the right then we'll know we'll just have to go
to the left to go home easy mode it loads sometimes it's
kind of oh ouch I'm dying I'm dying ouch I'm dying it's kind
of making me a
Now why did you hurt me?
Who hurt you?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Wait, now I'm like...
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Helmet removal?
No!
It's on, it's on.
I didn't remove it.
Who took my helmet off?
Creepy.
scary scary game scary your render distance was set to 32 oh
was it let's see okay yeah let's do let's do like yeah 12 is
a good yeah it wasn't what it said eight or higher all right
hopefully that fixes it I'm running I'm running through the
back rooms they can't stop me what are they gonna do poison
me what are you gonna do?
Make me sick in the head?
It won't let me eat.
Hmm.
Like I have all of these type bold true text.
And they gave me a compass, but it only says my location.
Maybe I should have maybe I should have took note of the
original location.
Whoa.
Is this free to play?
Yeah, everything that I got...
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Everything I got is free to play.
Sorry, kid.
Oh, cyber bully you too.
Eat peanut butter.
VTuber.
Is this a hole?
yeah I like that they use bees for the buzzing
you're allergic I would be so sad why can't we focus on the
important things forget about curing diseases we need to
cure ouch ouch ouch ouch we need to cure allergies to peanut
butter I'm gonna I'm gonna die, because I can't heal.
I'm gonna die for real.
I'm trying to eat.
The backrooms is preventing me from having a nice lunch.
Ouch.
I am right clicking!
Made Mint Phantom withered away.
Yeah, I'm using right click!
I know how to eat in Minecraft, but like...
It doesn't do anything.
Not the snacks room.
Maybe I need to take off the helmet to eat it?
Let's try.
What does that sound?
Nope.
Hmm.
We're back, baby.
I'm back in the back rooms.
You can't stop me.
Hmm.
Could we just be running?
Wait, what's down there?
This looks like a important area.
Just kidding.
I thought it was a hallway.
Poison, poison, poison!
Never mind.
How big is this map you think?
You're scared?
I don't think there's anything down here.
Just black mold.
Which is pretty scary, maybe.
Whoa!
Wait a second!
Ouch!
Wait, did the map change?
Did the map change?
Streamer does not read.
What am I supposed to be reading?
I think the compass is directing me.
Is it now?
We'll try it then.
It's pointing me to the wall.
Alright, let's go this way.
I'll try, I'll try it.
I'll try it with the compass.
It's not that I couldn't read, it's that the guy talked very
fast.
Let's see.
This way?
What about my helmet?
Ouch!
My helmet, I don't take it off, you guys.
That's just a thing that happens in this.
It says your helmet is...
I'm going forward.
Maybe we can run through it.
Yeah, see?
My helmet is on!
No, I'm basically making sure you've got the hazmat suit on.
If you haven't done the...
First, I've got to diagnose...
Diagnostic.
Okay.
I did all that.
The lever there.
Yeah, this is just activating it.
I was following the thing, but it wouldn't let me go
forward.
Okay.
Hmm.
What if all my...
Was there a person standing there?
Oh, I think it might have been the pole.
Guys, this is the real back rooms.
What if all my games are busted?
Wouldn't that be so funny?
You have to remove it and wear it again.
Really?
Is that how that works?
I'll try.
Oh.
I still died.
Oh no
Oh no I died still in the background Wait this is so cool up
until this point I can't eat my food My compass leads me to
death Okay hold on
Once we get to the spiky zone the spicy area that tries to
kill us well head backwards maybe the map changes or
something because it seemed like it did sometimes i would
like go forward and then it would eat me and i would turn
around there'd be a wall unless i just don't know what the
heck i'm doing which is
let me eat please
this maybe there's like only one direction one one direction
you don't know you're beautiful that's what makes you
beautiful have you ever thought of the lyrics of that song
you're in you're self-conscious and that's what makes you
attractive to me because you're not vain but you have no
confidence and that's what You're insecure.
Oh, ouch.
Don't know what for.
You're turning heads as you walk through the door.
What's in this dark area?
You would think darkness.
Like the evil kind that would eat, that's the spiky one.
My compass, it points to the direction that eats me.
I bet you think this song is about you.
Yeah, guys.
That song was made when I met One Direction.
I met them at a concert and they stopped the whole concert.
They were like, Stop the instruments!
Right now!
She's too beautiful!
And I'd be like, what do you mean?
Oh my gosh, no!
I'm just reading this book here.
I'm not interested in the boy band.
I'm just, I was just, I was just dragged here.
I'm just...
Oh my, I'm just a nerd with glasses.
I'm, I'm, I'm only interested in reading an anime.
I'm not beautiful at all.
You're insecure.
I don't know what for.
I went to...
Yeah, and that's when they wrote that song about me.
What if I put my glasses on?
Then I'll be able to read.
And we'll be able to play this game.
No spikes!
Tearing you!
Fine, kill me, kill me!
Mr. It's not working, please help.
Help!
I think this game might suck, Chief.
Oh, I had such high hopes, it was so good!
Please stop the beeping.
Next game.
You don't know that you're meant, Phantom.
This is two for two guys.
We're doing great.
I bet Escape from the Haunted Alcatraz is really good
though.
Trust.
Escape from Haunted Alcatraz, everybody.
It's probably amazing.
Can we blow up the maps after we're done with them?
Yeah.
What's this?
Oh,
there's music and everything.
Wait, is it my...
Oh, wait.
It changed my...
Look at that.
I'm going to turn the brightness up.
I can't see.
I just turned it up.
It changed my font and everything.
Everything.
What is this texture?
That's a real apple!
Game God.
Oh.
You need to sneak in order to pass obstacles.
Do not throw items in the tank except the oil.
What if I throw other things in there?
Spyglass.
Oh, well, look at that.
at that wait this is huge i'm sorry wait a second this is
ginormous there's so many places
oh my god most of the doors can be opened on the powerhouse
zoom in on the targeted block to see the number That's five?
Yeah, I can read.
Locks where you can place the levers.
Okay.
What am I sneaking past?
Alright.
Oh, like they want me to sneak in between these.
Wait, hold on.
One second.
Your maps are all on different Minecraft versions.
Yeah, but they should still work.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Back to the lobby.
All right.
Is this how we start the game?
Oh.
Is there supposed to be, like, a way to open it?
No, I think that's on purpose.
They're testing us.
They're like, can you use problem-solving skills?
what's in here gameplay game rules the island of Alcatraz
started its operation as a modern day correctional for
facility in 1934 it was the place where the most vicious
criminals and dangerous people were held as prisoners with
the worst treatment and inhumane living conditions during
its operation it was placed it was the place where many
people were tortured and died a ruthless death.
Alcatraz ceased its operation in March 21st, 1963.
For the coming years, screams and noises from the island
were heard to the surrounding area.
Terrorizing the people.
Oh my gosh.
Ah, guys, I'm a neighbor to Alcatraz and I can't sleep
because of all these screams and noises from the island that
is in the middle of the ocean.
As a reporter from San Francisco, you and your team are
visiting this phenomenon abandoned that's a phenomenally
abandoned island in February of 1966 to uncover the mystery
of the place and the source of those paranormal activities
and sounds
however due to the massiveness of the of the land yeah i'm a
little nervous you got lost in your group is nowhere to be
found now you have to face all challenges and dangers of
this cursed place and find a way out when you play this game
play it quietly and explore every little detail read
everything carefully and have fun following these rules
available for single player and multiplayer texture pack
comes with the map make sure to check the game guide do not
touch the paintings do not play this map with optifying
render distance 6 to 10 percent bio blend off brightness 50
60 this is fine this is fine those these are options these
are options It's graphics fancy.
For a better experience, oh, don't use that font.
Use headphones and play in a dark place.
Oh.
Wow, this is so cool.
Whoa.
One island.
Countless tormented souls.
I visited Alcatraz last month.
I didn't think it was very big.
Oh, escape from haunted Alcatraz!
Do not pass go and do not collect $200.
Warning.
Psychological fear and jump scares, you guys.
What are we going to be jump scared by?
It's abandoned.
Oh.
We're at Alcatraz.
Escape alive.
We're in Alcatraz.
Just swim.
Just swim away.
They should have that option where you can swim but you get
eaten by the sharks.
There's blood here!
And up there!
We're searching and we're going to be reading everything
carefully and having a good time.
As the game says.
I have some cooked chicken.
I have five cooked chickens.
Good thing I brought a snack with me, huh?
Oh, cooked pork chop!
A fishing rod and some...
This texture pack is wild.
Minky's current objective.
Survive.
Yeah.
Okay.
Useless.
Yeah.
Hasn't this place been abandoned for 30 years?
We're going to eat the cooked pork chop we found?
Not my wisest decision.
Somebody in here?
Am I going to die?
What's this?
Place the rudder parts here.
Oh, no.
There's blood in here too.
That's all I need to hear before I nope out of here.
Can I swim?
Not swim.
come rudder i hardly know her fear fishing fish fish fishing
you fearing you not so much in this game i'm fearing this
game i'm fearing this game
you think we can climb these let's go i'm escaping alcatraz
right now I can't stop me from climbing the the trees
It's okay A candle in the forest would not be allowed in
California I can tell you that much What's this?
A broken pile of sticks Yeah, broken The texture is broken a
little bit But that's okay We're still enjoying ourselves
Oh!
Oh, he gave me hunger.
Because I was so hungry looking at him.
No, please.
I'm so hungry looking at you, meat man.
No, no.
Fish him.
The warden's house.
Oh, gosh, I gotta get out of here.
Can I get a weapon?
Let's go in here and lock him out.
This is the...
Okay, I can't open doors.
Maybe.
Okay.
This is apartment.
Oh my gosh, why didn't I bring a weapon to the...
Oh my gosh, is this where you died?
Is that why you're angry?
I heard a...
Did you hear that?
The crow?
That was pretty good.
Where are we even?
We were at the warden's house.
Okay, oh, I thought I saw something move in there.
They can't open doors.
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Water bottles.
An exorcist note?
The island of Alcatraz, quote unquote, was the place where
many people have been tortured to death.
Many of them went crazy from the pain and the brutal
punishment they got.
Exorcist Krador was the man who executed exorcisms with his
exorcism stick.
No way.
11 out of 10 writing.
It's soul.
It's so good.
It does make sense.
His eyes saw suffering in bloody pictures as many of the
prisoners didn't make it.
They didn't survive the exorcism stick.
Crater, with the passage of time, became a scary and weird
man.
Due to the spooky things he saw, one day the Alcatraz
Potential.
What is that?
Are we really sure Shakespeare is dead?
Only three in and we got an intentionally scary map.
Hooray!
but this dialogue phenomenal
what's a alcatraz potential found him dead in this place the
chapel quote unquote where he used to make the exorcisms and
lived his whole life following his death many prisoners and
guards usually mentioned his frequent appearance to plenty
of places after the abandonment of the place His body is
still buried in the island's graveyard.
The abandonment of the place.
Are these supposed to be holy waters?
Can I drink these?
Oh, nice.
Not!
Holy cow!
So much pork chop!
Let's go.
Nobody's outside.
Luckily we can see.
If so or not.
Krador, regular California name.
I'm going to look up if this guy is real.
Exorcist Krador.
Oh, I hear him.
Uh-oh.
Husk groans.
You can't see it, but I have, like, the subtitles on.
That's where I came from, right?
Yeah, yeah, that's where I came from.
We're running.
Run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run.
To powerhouse.
Oh, didn't it say we need to turn the powerhouse on to open
the doors or something?
I think it said something like that.
Does John Faith use an exorcism stick to?
Yeah, actually.
Where are we?
What is this?
Oh, was that?
Oh, what is it?
Wait.
We're wrapped in.
Oh, it is.
That's a body.
Steve!
Where are we now?
Uh, there's like a courtyard there.
This is...
Wait, we haven't even gone into Alcatraz itself.
Holy.
Is this raw?
No, not the raw beef.
I'm guessing that's Alcatraz?
I need more
direction they like they said check out the map with your
spyglass and then oh the map with our spyglass but then
didn't um we can't keep using the map you know what I mean
dang they're loading us up on food
spooky ghost okay let's head that way.
Did I just trigger something?
Oh, no, I'm hearing campfires.
Oh, gosh.
No.
I think I'm in adventure mode.
Wait, no.
I need to get in there.
No, I can't go around.
Alcatraz, I don't know where I am.
What I'm doing?
What's this building, then?
Where is...
What is this?
Trust your instincts as a gamer.
Powerhouse!
Wait, let me in, please?
Does it need a key or something?
Shoot.
I can't get in.
I'm excited for the new outfit!
Thank you!
Thank you, Warden!
Uh-oh.
I hear a guy moaning and groaning.
I can't go inside anywhere.
So it's a little tough right now.
Uh, I'm lost.
They gave me a map once and said, Memorize it, Bozo.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, what's here?
Come on.
Okay.
Hmm.
Is this a downloadable mod pack?
Yeah, everything that I'm playing today?
Free!
Free to download?
Oh shoot.
We're so dead.
Maybe not.
Maybe I jukeed him.
What's here?
Have I been in here?
Island tunnel guide?
What do you mean by that?
Meat man is back.
The meat man cometh.
Prison cell beds are hiding a secret room that leads to the
underwater island tunnel, which prisoners use to escape from
Alcatraz.
Finding the secret entrance is easy, but you need to search
for a button code the items you are going to need are a
pickaxe which can be found in prison cell buildings and you
use it to break the beds a spy glass which i got uh used to
zoom in and spot the numbers into the cells guys write this
down 37 43 84 we need to look at the numbers in 37 43 and 84
find my code why did the architects of Alcatraz build the
secret escape tunnel I don't I don't know use them in the
valve which can be then later found in the tunnel this is so
easy guys this is so easy the order of the numbers to be
inserted to the valve is in correlation with the floor where
you found each number so like three four eight wait huh huh
valve button numbers what
oh i think i so wait the number the order of the numbers to
be inserted to the valve is in the correlation where you
found each number so it would be like oh wait
first floor first number okay yeah so say we're on the first
floor and it's number three wait that makes no sense though
wait we'll
just keep this with us we'll keep this with us i like the
the you can hear like the crows cawing and stuff but it's
actually chickens that's so cute oh shoot i'm trying to
climb
oh my gosh that guy with that that not skelly was impaled
uh-huh oh huh trying to see if there's anything else over
here I don't know where to go though nothing will open I
said you need to open the powerhouse but I'm still not
hungry
powerhouse parade square is that the place where they hung
people and you're calling it a parade square oh look oh you
guys we found a map let me end please
I heard a guy.
I heard a husk.
Where we are at...
Uh...
Here-ish, I guess?
64 building?
Which...
But we need to get into the prison.
Cells, somehow.
A little confused.
Husk be groanin.
Meat man.
Ah!
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I bet you can't climb.
I bet you don't know how to climb.
Oh.
Oh, man.
He'll forget about me.
Look at that guy full of meat.
What if I land on him Mario-style?
That'll kill him.
Here I go.
Oh.
Um.
Shoot.
Ouch.
Just run.
He can't catch up.
How do I get into this building now?
I didn't know he was right.
He is right behind me, isn't he?
I don't know.
Okay, this is the...
What is this?
Is this the apartment?
apartments or whatever 64 building I can't get in it won't
let me in anywhere no doors open can I crawl here can I
crawl up up here can I crawl oh my gosh is there a door to
crawl can I crawl can I crawl through I don't want to get
attacked how do I get inside
door stuck door stuck the warden's house it's all boarded up
oh he can smell me I mean I did shower probably thinks I
have really nice shampoo there's like the warden is here
this place is not abandoned who's lighting these these
candles and guys I'm not quite sure what to do oh come on
out leave me alone
leave me alone this
one has such potential
bye the real horror the game that we're telling you how to
play the game i think this one told us but it was like a
little convoluted yeah this was the best one yet we got a
jump scare we got we got a jump scare out of this at least
that's very exciting
i'm beginning to think that none of these minecraft horror
maps are horrific says you uh we're about to do We're about
to do...
The smiling illusion.
We still have this and back to school.
I think this is actually the correct...
Oh.
Sure, just go.
Map by...
Vendomill.
Settings.
What did I do?
The smiling one?
Oh,
this was the smiling illusion.
Okay, back to school is definitely going to be awesome.
We're going back...
Back to school!
Oh.
Oh, texture packs.
Wait, what just happened?
ate the book?
Wait, what actually just happened?
Where did the book go?
I didn't get to read it.
I ate the...
Oh, wait.
I thought there was a... No.
This one has music at least and stuff.
Teacher, Minto ate my homework.
Sorry, teach the Minky ate my homework.
I'm so confused legitimately what happened to it.
I ate the homework.
I ate it.
I don't want to save and quit.
I don't want to save.
We're going back to school.
I really thought that these would be...
I actually think...
I thought...
I was like, oh, I downloaded so many games.
I was like, I downloaded so many games that...
Maybe we do have to do 1.10.2.
Hold on.
Let's hold on.
I'll try.
I'll give this one a genuine shot.
1.10.2 is it?
Yeah.
That's old.
No?
That's pretty old.
Okay.
Save.
Alright, let's close out.
Alright, let's see if it loads.
Okay.
That's quite old, yeah.
Let's see.
Wait.
This is an older game version that doesn't support the
latest player.
That's fine, that's fine.
Play it anyway.
Weird because the map said it was updated this year.
No way!
Actually, this was the only one that I couldn't find.
I couldn't re-find it once I downloaded it.
Like on the site that I downloaded it.
I was like, what if this is an actual car?
It was the old Mojang logo.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Wow.
I've never seen this menu before ever.
World was saved in a newer version.
Loading this world could...
Can I...
Can I redo it?
Does recreate fix it?
maybe
guys the haunted school the
haunted school everybody wow we
yeah we'll have to delete it make a new one probably oh man
okay hold on I still have of the folder, I think.
One second.
This is so stupid!
The thing with those maps is that they're mostly scripted
with data packs and commands, and Minecraft devs have been
changing and updating them every few versions, so maps made
for older versions might be completely broken.
I didn't think it would be that broken.
I didn't think they would be so broken.
Okay, hold on.
like the app data and nantokan nantokan nantokan oh oh app
data wait app data hold on i'm going to the website
let's see there we go they give you the thing for your
computer okay all right now we have back to school.
1.0.
1.1.1.10.
Alright.
There it is.
I'm still having fun with these, though.
Oh my gosh!
You are Daniel.
Damn, Daniel.
An elementary school teacher who was arrested on suspicion
of the murder of Martin.
A student of his class.
Daniel will start investigating the murder on his own.
Play in land mode so that the game does not stop.
Auto jump you can use creative if there is a bug.
Okay.
Oh my gosh the sensitivity is kind of wackadoo.
How do I read this?
Oh, we're going.
Yahoo!
I earned a achievement even.
There's a cutscene!
Oh, Martin!
Yeah, permission to cheat.
Well, they shouldn't, whatever is wrong, like, if there's,
like, a ghost haunted.
here it shouldn't want to kill me because i'm i'm not the
killer right surely
back to school
a jailbreak wait this is one week later this is pretty crazy
tape recorder listen and those are all the past news stories
for and to say goodbye from the editorial office we want to
continue showing all our support to the family and friends
of Martinova the boy killed in the school of Ernesto Serola
a week ago which will continue to be closed for the entirety
of the month in current news research has come to an impasse
new to recently released teacher arrested on the first week
that's me my notes in this notebook I will write down the
data of my research on the death of my students page one of
one and I have some keys okay it won't let me run that's
fine I'm guessing I don't have an umbrella either yes new
notes oh I have to find a way to get into the school try to
move that container push What container?
Okay, the sensitivity...
Oh, this one.
The sensitivity on this is kind of crazy, though.
The dumpster?
I'm pushing it.
Look at me go.
Oh!
Why is it so bouncy?
Wait!
Ouch!
I wish I could run.
This...
school this is an elementary school do not enter authorized
personnel only this is not an elementary school are we for
real right now this is like a college whoa what's over here
we got music and everything this goes hard
New notes.
Oh, I have to write them and then I throw my notebook and
then I can... The front door is closed.
I'll try to get in the gym.
Okay?
The gym is obviously...
Uh...
Over here.
Never mind.
The gym is obviously...
Over here.
Never mind.
This feels like Outlast.
Is it going to be as scary as Outlast?
One thing that always takes me out of like a Minecraft
horror thing is the way that my arm just sticks out the
entire time.
The gym.
Can we jump over this?
No?
It's usually the sounds for me.
Yeah, but they can fix that with texture packs and stuff
like that.
this game.
You can remove your hand.
I know, but it's so funny.
What are you telling me to take off my hand?
Telling me to remove my hand?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, I have no hunger.
Yeah, we unfortunately can't run, it seems.
Oh, yes we can.
Oh, they changed my controls, so now shift is...
Shift is run.
I mean, shift is sneak and...
Like, that's such a Minecraft sound, isn't it?
How do I open it?
Are those my footsteps?
Oh, they are!
What the heck?
That's so cool.
footsteps can I ask you for your hand I need this I need
this
how do I use the key now did
that unlock it
not square footsteps immersion ruin wait you're so right
you're so right do I have to jump in from the top.
Wait, I got this.
Did you try both keys?
Yeah.
What?
I had it almost the first time.
Dang it.
You guys, I right clicked them.
Now I'm right clicking the door.
I'm right clicking.
no I'm left-clicking I'm left-clicking
oh wait what's this I'm writing I will break the glass with
some stone or brick oh okay
dang hold on I have to I have to change I can't do I can't
do control My pinky does not like it.
Sneak.
Uh-huh.
Cricket, cricket, cricket, cricket.
Wait, will it not let me go back again?
Okay, once we've gone this way, we cannot go back.
Let's see, let's find a rock or something.
Is this a rock?
No?
I mean, I don't think that could be used to break the
window, but...
Is that a rock or what?
Some stone or brick?
Hmm.
Take a brick from the wall?
Punch it with my hands.
I think I saw someone near around the wall.
I saw some?
Hmm.
Maybe on the other side?
I feel like I saw some...
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Nice.
The dog's barking.
The dog is alerting the guards.
What's this?
Nothing.
We're in...
We're back to school!
I will go to my office and take the key to the fifth grade
class.
room i definitely know where that is i 100 know where that
is is
that the sound of the door locking wait how could it lock oh
when we can't go back it like it lot it prevents us back to
school activities wait they drew her smoking a weed adding
breaking and entering to our list of crimes oh yeah i mean
wait half a life doing a dance school no way no way wait oh
for this one it says the dues are 20 dollars but then for
the summer camp it says it's 150 euro or 150 pound so where
are we Where in the world are we?
Spooky basketball!
Oh.
We can kick it.
We can play basketball.
World Cup?
You guys voting for...
You guys voting for my country?
What's this?
Dirt.
My office is...
Hmm.
Very obvious where my office is.
It's not in the caretaker's house.
Why do we have... Why doesn't elementary school have a
caretaker?
On the ground.
Wee!
That was kind of spooky.
Oh.
Double.
Whoa.
Oh, wait.
It ate both of my keys.
How cinematic.
Guys, this is scary.
Is that my office?
Oh, gosh.
The sensitivity on this is really crazy for some reason.
This
is...
Huh.
Reading gives us some place to go and we have to stay where
we are.
Think before you trash.
Is this my office?
Wee-wee.
Are we upstairs?
This place is humongous.
Like, huge.
Oh.
Is this my office?
Where are we?
Ooh.
Yeah?
Thanks for always being a standout positive energy when
people needed the most.
You're awesome, Guber.
Anime Exo, I bought so many prints and sandies of you.
I was given a free mint tote bag.
Spiraling Delusion.
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Thank you.
School equals prison confirmed by that poster.
Okay, we have this room with the power.
I think the power works though.
Wait, this looks like it's by my...
Primary classrooms.
Wait.
Okay, wait, but where's my office?
So there are...
Uh...
is oh yes I'm trying there's an invisible wall is this my
office there must be multiple grades here then right take it
someone okay thanks take it oh here we go key for the
teacher's office someone is here I have to be carefully.
They threw the brick at me!
It's probably the caretaker.
He's probably like, hey man!
You're trespassing.
I have to be carefully.
This is so cool so far though.
There's so much you can do in Minecraft.
You know?
That you never would know.
I am.
I'm being careful, please.
No smoking in the teacher's office.
Is this my office?
One thing I think it could use is...
This is going to sound really stupid, but like, gamer paint
in that...
In that, you...
When you get... You don't have to, like, get on top of
something for, like, the little high...
light to appear it does sometimes I'm clicking what yes I'm
observing is the window gonna break again oh hello Daniel I
have heard recently heard that you have been released I'm
sorry that they arrested you for being at the crime scene
although I know that you just wanted to help Martin it has
certainly been a difficult week today we have met the
teachers to decide what we will do with you for the moment
you will you will you will you will take a sick sick leave
we have also changed all the locks i'm so sorry best regards
directed all director alfonso to be or not to be or to be
carefully karta or daniel so definitely a game where uh
english is not the first language It's a translated game.
That's totally okay, though.
Thanks, thank goodness the director leaves his...
Oh, his...
Nota de director!
What was that?
I have left the keys of the primary classrooms in the
caretaker's house.
I will not be coming in a couple of weeks because of what
happened at school.
Says the director.
Director!
This is literally your job!
The director has like nothing in here so we gotta go to the
caretaker's home
i'm the director and i say whatever happened is way too much
for me
i will go to the caretaker's house way ahead of you buddy
cool are we breaking in it i mean we already broke and
entered into the school I don't think entering this guy's
house is gonna be any worse, huh?
Where did we come from?
What was that?
Yeah, we came from reading.
What is this?
Is this like a...
Oh, just more lockers, I guess.
These humongous lockers for all the elementary school kids.
Imagine the number of children you can fit in here.
The sound effects are pretty creepy.
I think what happens is...
Oh, a dog!
I think what happens is you hear the door opening of like...
Ah!
Oh my god!
There's an actual dog in here!
Can you get me?
No.
Come on.
What's up, boy?
Um...
So I don't think it's necessarily like, you know, because
this door opened and we heard it open kind of situation.
Wow.
He's even got a baby changing table.
Uh-huh.
Where are the keys, Mr. Caretaker?
I'm so glad he's not home.
Hi,
I'm the director here.
I left the keys of the primary classrooms in the Caretaker's
house.
Thanks.
I will not be coming in a couple of weeks because of what
happened at school.
Slap's top.
This locker holds like...
Oh my god!
Martin's calling me!
Martin's calling.
Now I can investigate in classroom number five where I was
tutor.
I thought we were a teacher.
Are we tutoring the kids or are we like full-on, you know...
I would bring the dog.
Was that a dokeybird?
That's horrible.
He was tuber.
I will now go to classroom number five where I was vtuber.
Oh, sorry.
I can't go from here, though, right?
I'll just step over the rope, right?
Like a normal person would?
Just, it's, it's a, it says do not cross, but You don't have
to, you don't have to...
Oh,
I think I go in here and probably turn it off.
Nice.
Are all the lights off now?
No.
We did something.
That was pretty neat, though.
That was a cool effect.
That's the teacher's office.
here yeah I'm going really slowly there we go classroom
number five oh no way why did they oh this is the basement
store is this the room that we needed to go into someone has
closed the door to access primary classrooms I'll try to
access by the store okay
Go into the basement for...
What?
How do we access by here?
We dig up?
Minecraft?
Probably.
This does not feel like a Minecraft mod.
It's kind of crazy.
Oh no!
Are you sure?
It doesn't feel like a Minecraft mod?
When you see...
Oh gosh, this looks like we're gonna get chased.
Oh, chase through here.
something here O'Brien hey wait can I act oh wait there we
go oh deeper into the basement oh thank you for the red
hello hi everybody we're playing this awesome Minecraft mod
oh I sure hope I don't know how to get chased through here.
This looks like an absolute chase zone, huh?
Hey, KSTF2.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Dora, go.
Thank you so much for the fine gifted.
Alright.
We made it.
Where are we?
Cafeteria?
Eerie noise.
Nah, well, thank you.
This is a basement storage, so it's got to be...
somewhere down here
yes oh no the caretaker oh no oh my god no wonder he wasn't
in his house i don't know what has happened the caretaker is
is dead i need to find clues to solve martin's murder and
get out as up here as soon as possible oh my god oh
Primary classrooms.
Down here.
Number two.
Oh.
I want to say it was such a pleasure meeting you, Vicky and
Phoebe at Smash!
Even though it was brief, I'll cherish that moment forever
as it was my first ever meet-and-greet.
Vita for meet-and-greet, thank you!
Thank you so much for coming to see us!
Thank you, thank you.
Three.
Four.
Dun, dun.
Duh!
Oh, the bathroom?
Wait, I thought...
You could have said he was taken care of.
Was this where he...
Oh my god!
Oh!
They didn't even clean up the blood of the kid?
Whoa.
We just had like a little memory.
Poor man didn't realize this was actually his first name,
last name, taker.
Here they found Martin.
He had many wounds from a sharp weapon.
And here was where I was arrested.
I will go to class number five.
It was a flashback.
This is so cinematic.
Number five.
Here we go.
What clues can we find in here?
find, you know?
Minto, why did you kill that guy?
I did it!
Wait, I'm trying...
There we go.
Hello?
What am I clicking on?
Am I supposed to investigate this thing?
Yes, I'm clicking on it.
New notes.
I will send this super chat to Minto.
Thank you.
Maybe from far away.
Uh-oh.
No.
No!
Oh.
Guys, it might be Jover.
It might be Jover.
It's take care over.
No!
It was going so well.
This one was actually so cool.
Oh, what the heck?
They're making these children learn on unfinished blocks of
wood.
Imagine all the splinters these children are receiving.
It's just plywood.
Creative mode.
Oh, how do I do that?
Wait.
How do I get to, uh...
What was it?
Um, game mode...
Creative?
I don't know.
Help.
Slash default game mode mode.
Slash default game mode.
Creative.
mode creative no slash game mode one oh wait did it work oh
yes it did
oops i don't know what this is gonna do though
uh i could do a moss stone oh But it looks like a child.
Oh, oops.
Oh, shoot.
Did your notes update?
No.
I think this is over.
I think it's over, guys.
No.
Wait, we were doing so well.
There is no class six.
And class...
thing I'm outside Wow who's that oh that's the guy that's
the police officer that's that's our memory oh no we didn't
get to see all the children who's you
oh the police officer nope sorry The caretaker.
Oh, he's alive!
The caretaker is alive!
He's alive!
I don't think there's a way to proceed, unfortunately.
As it will not let me.
Now I can pet the dog.
Yes.
Oh, that guy.
Bye.
There's a good boy.
Be free.
Be free, dog.
I gift you.
I gift you the power to leave.
Hmm.
What could it be?
What could it be preventing him from leaving?
No.
They won't let him go.
They won't let him go!
These blasted ghosts!
He's trapped forever.
The command block?
I think that might erase his existence.
Wait, he's in there.
Oh god.
Watch him go.
Never mind.
All right, let's see if he goes.
I give up
Sorry guys This one was fun though What we got to play These
were fun I want to properly be able to play them
You know I want to properly be able to play some of these
Maybe we can Maybe the back rooms one sometime or something
this this is no school for children though this is spawning
a gun and one bullet yeah this is no school for children my
car can I get in it I'm going down the highway no the sign
we We could go to the sun.
The sun isn't real.
It's a P&D.
But we have to get close to it sometime.
Probably.
The sun at night?
The sun is always around.
You just can't see it sometimes.
How do they make the world so small?
Is it like a world built underneath another world?
See, there's like a hazy part of this.
Oh.
Nope, just clouds.
Wait, what's that over there?
What was that?
There's...
Oh.
Yes, there's stuff over here.
wait there's chess whoa gosh the inner machinations of these
things are so crazy I
wonder what these did what is your command
needs redstone crazy
whoa what's over here this looks like something we're
teleported to.
Wait, there's a chest here.
Normus.
Oh.
Like the rules and stuff.
What's here?
Wait, this is the...
This is the bathroom that we were in.
And where he was dead.
Hmm.
Maybe he was testing something with it.
Oh, maybe this is for the cutscene.
Like the cutscene part of it?
Maybe?
Like the child.
Oh, a spooky child.
Cool.
Aww.
Anyway.
I hope you guys had fun.
With our little back rooms.
And.
Alcatraz.
and skew and what else what is so much happening here we
should do more Minecraft horror mods a lot of these are
multiplayer too so getting some people in on it too would be
a lot of fun so I will see about doing that in the future
I'm going to throw this kid
sorry the last one bugged for you it was really well done
regardless I had a lot of fun Yeah, I'm fun too, even though
these were all so silly.
The anomaly one, okay, I'm gonna say it.
The anomaly one is the only one that worked.
Curse of quiet, thank you for the super chat.
The anomaly one is the only one that properly worked.
To be fair though, we did not probably do the backrooms one
on the proper...
On the proper...
like what's the word
version yeah game version um also I want to try some of the
like I wanted to see if I could get some of the like not
just Minecraft maps but some horror mods as well for like
vanilla Minecraft well I guess it's not vanilla if you had a
mod but you know what I mean like you play normal Minecraft
but then there's crazy things Alcatraz seemed to work but it
was confusing Yeah, I just don't, I don't know if me, I
mean, we had that, we had one jump scare.
I don't know if it's the, because we needed the power on, I
don't know.
It was very, it was, hmm.
Yeah, Alcatraz had no direction.
It was kind of hard to tell if it was me or the game.
There are some spooky mods out there.
There are.
I like to watch videos of them sometimes.
They're fun.
I have orange carpet.
I don't know where I got that from.
But yeah, this is fun.
Thank you guys for joining me for some spooky Minecraft nist
today.
I'm stuck in a spider web.
I'm ruining things now.
I'm just breaking it all.
I'm breaking.
Oh, the director.
I'm breaking it all.
Break the game.
Nothing will work.
If I can't have it, nobody can.
Yeah!
What's that?
The basketball!
Wait!
Break stuff.
Give me some to break!
How about this freaking block?
I hope you know I pack creative mode.
What's this?
Oh, this is the beginning.
This is where we actually teleported from.
The rules!
The normas!
The...
Normas and normas and normas and normas.
It's weird seeing the sphere of Minecraft.
Dworkah!
Thank you so much for the pink!
The horrors of version incompatibility and glitchiness may
not have been what we were expecting, but it was lots of fun
hanging out.
Hope you have a great night and hopefully no spooky dreams
from the scary maps.
Thank you!
Oops.
It was fun.
I want to do more.
I'll find some I don't know, was this one, did this say I
don't think this said it was multiplayer, I think this one
was just single player I believe But there's other ones for
sure that we can do with other people
Ernesto Sororola I saw you at SmashCon I was so happy, thank
you Oh, you and Vibi and Vicky were so funny in their
concert.
So it was awesome.
So happy you guys could come to Sydney and Vinto live.
Jago, thank you.
Thanks for coming to see us.
Thank you, thank you.
It does say two plus players.
Let's go.
How many spooky maps did you download?
All of the ones that we played today.
Which I truly thought they would work and that we would have
a lot of time and do a bunch of...
Do, you know.
But...
Regardless, I still had...
A lot of fun.
And I hope you did too.
But if someone actually got this mod and then went into
creative and destroyed the bit that you needed to proceed,
then that's why you can't go further.
I don't even know where we were at in the game.
We were in some classroom.
But I think we can't access anymore.
We saw running children, though.
That was fun.
This was a great mod.
if only it didn't bug in that one spot it would be perfect
if it didn't bug in that one spot whoa i like i like that
our feet on the ground and everything like it's so cool yes
thank you guys thank you thank you and if you have any um
any horror maps or mods that you please specify which is
which if you're like this is a horror mod for playing
minecraft or this is a horror map for for it then please
specify but if you have any recommendations please comment
them down below i would like to find some more and do this
in the future and hopefully bring in some other people as
well we were in the classroom looked like someone got an f
on their test yeah i think it offended our teacher
sensibilities too much to pick it up
Minto meet and greet at green star off kai sunday july 26th
at 5 p.m i booze come say hi to fu minto now on off kai's
meetup website totally real trust big seymour see you there
where was a green star at off kai yeah rest easy minky this
is fun thank you for the stream minto thank you guys thank
you thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
I will see you guys when I see you next and Yeah, I'm like
going I'm checking discord every two seconds to be like To
be like is it is it is did I get a what did I did I did I
hear back about what I need Black Lance.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Hopefully you hear back soon about the outfit.
We will be waiting i it will be monday at the latest monday
at the latest um for the new outfit tomorrow if all if i
wake up and everything is amazing but right now it's a
little well a little tough to say unfortunately but yeah
thank you so much everybody thank you i'm i unfortunately
feel it a bit in my ectoplasmic bones that it might be
delayed but if it's not then i will be very excited for
tomorrow thank you everybody thank you thank you thank you
so much bye bye have a good day have a good night have a
good time thank you thank you see you bye bye bye bye bye bye